you now when it comes to fighting the
coronavirus getting vaccinated
one of the best things health officials
say we can do and that's why there was a
big push tonight to motivate younger
people
to get vaccinated get shots as athletes
along with city and county leaders came
together
to share that message madison kimbrough
was there
and tells us a bit more about the
hashtag
get vaxxed envy event hi madison
yes now this is a live streamed event
had prominent figures in our community
speak about the facts and benefits of
getting vaccinated
and how it's so much more than just a
shot but a way of working together
to keep each other safe i think there's
certainly an invincibility issue but
there's also a fact versus fiction
issue that we're facing as well clark
county commissioners partnered with the
space
tuesday night to host an informative
live streamed event
called get vaxxed nv the goal encourage
those 16 to 25 years old to get their
vaccination shots
that's why it was important that we have
this honest conversation we have health
care experts here to answer questions
the program lasted for about an hour and
allowed people to ask questions
unlv athletes some of the raiders and
the chief medical officer of the
southern nevada health district
were on hand to encourage people to take
the shot
it's the most selfless thing you could
do right now for your community
it's the most selfless thing you could
do for our economy is to make sure that
what is in your power is to get yourself
vaccinated and by doing that we can
reopen
and after the discussion those in
attendance who wanted to get their
vaccine were able to get it
right then and there by the clark county
fire department and snhd
us at the clark county fire department
have always been
very supportive of our community members
and what they feel that they want to get
vaccinated with and
we're here with the pfizer vaccine and
johnson johnson vaccine
and you can find more information on
where to get vaccinated on our website
8newsnow.com
reporting live in the newsroom madison
kimbrough 8 news now
vaccine